RICH IANNONE: GT I'm super
excited about this, because I
have so much good stuff.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
RICH IANNONE: OK, so
I got this new thing.
So I call this file
intendo-rev. It's basically
revenue from a fake game
company called Intendo.
You never heard of it
because it doesn't exist.
OK, so library(gt), we
need that, got to have it.
And then we're going
to do library(intendo).
It's a hard package to get.
It's on GitHub.
If you just search it
up, you will find it.
And the cool thing
about it is it has
datasets of different sizes.
And we'll use all those
datasets for this.
It'll be so nice.
And I like to library
tidyverse, because we're
going to use all
sorts of tidyverse
before making the actual
table, the data table.
And then we're going to get
in lubridate, because going
to do some date and time stuff.
I'm never sure whether
that's included in tidyverse.
I think it isn't.
OK, so great.
So I'm going to get all the
revenue just by assigning it
to this.
So Intendo has a
bunch of datasets
like all revenue, all sessions.
I'm trying to get the revenue.
I'm just going to
do that right here.
The default options are good.
This is the size of the dataset.
We'll just go for small,
because we don't want
to tax the system too much.
So we're going to get the data.
Doing some stuff here, but
it just downloads the data
from the repo.
And now we can totally see it.
I'm going to make the
console just a bit bigger,
because we'll do some
console stuff, initially.
So lots of rows of data,
like nearly 200,000.
Whoa.
OK, it's a lot of revenue.
This company is doing
well, which is great.
Good for Intendo.
But it has lots of
countries in it,
and we're going to filter
down this data quite a bit.
We're going to actually
make something super narrow.
So, in the end, we definitely
don't want more than 50 rows,
I think, to fit a
table on the screen.
So we're going to
happily summarize this.
So, first thing
we're going to do
is make a vector for
subsetting the countries.
So I'll just set
countries to consider.
So I'll call it countries.
Then I'm just going to make
a vector of countries I know
using the two letter codes.
So I think it's US, Great
Britain, we'll put in DE, CH,
we'll make it a top eight.
Norway.
This is Canada.
Then we'll do India
and Spain, which ES.
So that's eight, right?
Yeah, that's totally eight.
Perfect.
I'll keep them on the same line.
Good.
So now we have this.
This is some sort of
prep work we need to do.
So we have that.
Well, first of all, we have all
these times for the revenue.
We want to break it
down to each month.
We're going to summarize for
each month what the revenue was
for each type of revenue.
I'll just go over
this table a bit.
So I'll tell you exactly
what this all is.
So each player in
the game has an ID.
Each time they play the
game, they have a session,
and that has an ID as well.
There's a session start and
the time of the revenue event.
So each row is a revenue event,
like a purchase of something.
And they can buy
either an IAP, which
is an in-app purchase,
usually some sort of currency,
or secondary currency,
or some game item,
or some special offer that's
a combination of things.
And then there's a
revenue associated
with that bought item.
And actually, there's
two different types.
There's also item name,
might be IAP or ads.
So ad views will also result
in some revenue as well.
OK, and then there's
a session duration.
So just the amount of time
they were in that session.
It's good analytics to have,
to see how long they're playing
and what triggered the sale.
A start date, this
is historical data.
It's a start date
for that player.
So we can get the
player age from that.
So it's kind of a
redundant thing,
but it's good to have
because you can segment all
this data by the player age.
And then we have other
things to do with the player,
like their
acquisition, basically
where they were acquired from.
What ad caused him to play the
game or convert into the game?
So it could be other
networks like Facebook
or ads on different platforms
that got them into the game.
Usually they are
represented with the link
and then they install the
app that way, the game.
And then the country
they're from,
which is basically come
coarse location data, which
is just provided by MaxMind.
OK, so we have all that.
So now we really want
to just break this down
into country, month, item type,
and then the total revenue.
And we're going to
be a table from that.
It's going to be
really pretty sweet.
So now we got the
countries considered.
We explained the data
little bit there.
So now, we want to
get the month names.
Because, in the end, we'll
just have one, two three,
until 12 as the column names.
But we want to make them
friendly nice month names.
So we'll do that.
I just found this
out today, actually.
There's a month name vector
in R, which is kind of cool.
We just need the
first three letters.
So we'll do substring
from one to three,
and we'll see that
gives us just this.
And then later on, we
need this as a list
to change the
column names in GT,
which is a little
bit inconvenient,
but that might change later.
We'll just make it
a list, like this.
OK, great.
So now we'll just get this.
I don't really like lists
because they're annoying,
but we have no choice.
So we have to make this list.
So we'll call this
month names, like so.
And another weird thing about
GT is it needs a named list,
because it has to map the
column name with the new label.
So these will act
as labels, but we
need the name of each item in
the list as the actual column
name.
So that's not too
bad, because we know
they're going to be one to 12.
So let's just do
names(month_names)--
so many names--
as.character(1:12).
OK, so now if we do this, and
we take a look at month names,
we finally have this
preparation step right here.
This will be good for later.
Just doing it ahead
of time because it's
annoying to deal with it later.
OK, so now all the revenue.
We're going to start there.
We're going to build up this
table one line at a time, maybe
bunches of lines at a time.
But we'll see it
every step of the way.
So right now, we don't
even have it in GT.
We still have this.
And we still to do lots of
stuff before we get the GT.
For instance, we need
to do that month thing.
So we'll do mutate(month
= lubridate).
And then we want to
use the month function,
and we want to use it on
the time column right there.
That's the time of
the revenue event.
So I'm just going to run this.
You won't see it, because
it's actually at the end,
but trust me.
It's just the month as a number.
To continue, filter.
We're going to filter
a lot, because we
don't need a ton of
stuff in this table
because we want to focus a bit.
There's lots of
data in this table,
but we want to just
focus on a few things.
Otherwise, it gets
too multidimensional.
So we'll say item.type is going
to be just the "iap" type.
And again, it's in-app purchase,
things people buy and not
ads people watch.
OK, so that brings
down the table down
to 47,000 rows, which is
a lot better than before.
One thing we don't see
here, and this is something
from the data, is the country.
It is a long country name.
It's not a country
code, which is fine.
But it's big and it's
hard to work with.
A weird thing about
GT is, it actually
has this countrypops dataset,
which has great data.
But the cool thing is,
it has a bunch of country
names and the country
codes, and they just
happen to map perfectly
with this dataset.
So we can actually do a join
and get the country codes
from this.
And you get the two
letter country codes.
Either one is good,
but just for this one,
we're just going
to work with that.
So I'm going to do
a left_join as we
want to join that table
on existing data that
isn't what we have here.
And it's going to be
gt::country_pops, the dataset.
And we're going to
filter that just
by those first two columns.
So country_name, and
what is the other one?
country_code, too.
Right, so we filter that down.
Now you just get
those two columns.
So we'll just make
that distinct(),
so we have 170 or so rows.
And then, we'll do by, because
it'll be two different names.
And I believe
construction is the c,
and then to quoted things.
The left side are all
the revenue table,
and this is the
country_pop side.
So this side is going
to be "country_name"
and this one will be, I
think, just "country."
OK, let's run this now
and see if it works.
Totally works.
We got country_code_2 in there.
We'll change all these names
later, promise you that.
So we did a left join.
There's a ton of stuff to
do before we get to a table,
I know.
But we got so much data.
We have no choice.
OK, now I'm going to
do another mutate().
OK, and the thing I'm going
to do here is say, OK.
So we have these IAPs.
We're going to stretch
this out just a little bit
so we can see here, because it's
almost impossible to see what
we have in terms of the types.
There we go, item names.
So we have different
tiers of gold offer.
There's not just gold,
there's also gems, I believe.
But we just want to lump
them together into one type.
So all we got to do
is take off a digit.
We don't do any regular
expressions or anything.
Just take off the digit.
Oh yeah, we do have to
do a regular expression.
We have to identify the
digit and just take it off.
So this is super simple.
So we're going to call this
iap_type as a new thing.
And we're just
going to do a gsub.
Up Then we're going to look
for any digit, so just "0-9"
and it's only just one, so
we don't have to put any sort
of star here or
anything like that.
And we're just going to
replace it with nothing.
And then that's going
to be item name.
OK, let's see that
this actually worked.
Great, it didn't error,
which is fantastic.
We got iap_type,
and I'm trusting
that this number is gone.
So that sort of lumps
things together.
So we have less
dimensions to worry about.
OK, continuing we're going to
select a few things to really
narrow down this
table, So we actually
can see it on one screen.
So we're going to
select a country,
and that is currently as
country_code_2, great.
And then the other
thing is we're
going to select our
month, iap_type,
and what else do we need?
Item_revenue, of
course, in that order.
Because these will be
things we group on.
And then the last
thing will just
be the thing we
want to summarize.
OK, let's look at this now.
Great.
Much shorter, much less wide.
Still lots of rows, but
summary will take care of that.
Summarize will.
So we're going to group by
basically all the things like
month, iap_type, then country.
We're going to pass
that into summarize().
We're going to call
this total_rev,
and it's just going to be
the sum of item_revenue.
And then there's
this groups argument
that I always forget to
select or to use, and always
gives me a warning.
So I'm going to use it now.
And I think "drop"
is what you want.
I'll put on the second line.
That's closed off.
OK, let's take a look now.
Much less rows, I'm hoping.
No.
OK, sorry I don't
use the shortcut,
because I just
never did do that,
and maybe that's a
case for doing it.
OK, much less.
765 plus 10 rows.
775.
That is great.
OK, so now we're going
to arrange stuff.
It's always good to arrange it
and see if things make sense.
So I'm going to arrange
by month, country,
and iap_type and
take a look again.
Great.
And arranging is
actually super important
before you get into GT
anyway, because you're going
to have arranged data in GT.
Some things you
can change, though.
But it's good to arrange it a
bit because it's for display.
OK, now that we
arranged it, we're
going to use pivot_wider
to take the months
and put them as columns.
OK so pivot_wider.
And I believe this is
names_from and then values_from.
I'll select it down here.
So names are from month.
Put that in quotes?
No, I don't think you
need to put quotes.
Month.
Values_from total_rev.
Great, now we're going to see
the table being super wide,
I'm hoping.
Yes.
So we partially have
column names being numbers,
but they're in backticks, so
they're OK to access that way.
And you can
actually, even in GT,
access them by quoted numbers.
So it's not too bad.
So now we have this.
We're going to pipe
that into GT, finally,
and we'll see how this looks.
I'm going to bring this up, so
we can actually see the table.
OK, great.
So now we have a
GT table, finally.
I'm going to make
this a bit wider.
So now we can see that we
have all this stuff in here,
which is great.
It's a bit long, but we
can totally change this.
One thing we might note is
that, the structure's fine,
but we have things which
are great for grouping.
We have names here for rows.
And we have groups,
which are the countries.
So in the gt() call
itself, we have rowname_col
and groupname_col.
We're going to use both.
So for rowname_col, we're
going to use, in quotes,
it's going to be "iap_type."
And for groupname_col,
it's going to be "country."
Great, OK.
So now running this, it
gets arranged a little bit
differently.
So now we have it like
this, which is kind of cool.
So now we have
countries like this.
They're not arranged in a way
that we want it to be arranged,
but we can fix that.
Also, I don't want all
these countries here
because we do have a
countries_considered.
So we didn't actually
filter before.
But that's cool,
because with this code,
we can definitely change
it and then it's all good.
So I think it's
country at this point?
Yeah, country %in%
countries_considered.
Yeah, and then
join it with pipe.
Now this table, because
I just ran this code,
should be less countries now.
Great, that's perfect OK so now
it's like less big of a table.
It's focused a bit.
OK so now we have this,
we're going to continue on.
So now we have a
table, at least.
So we're in table
territory in GT.
Now we can do all
sorts of things
to shape it while
we're in the GT API.
One thing you might
want is the countries
to be in order that we want,
just because we decided
beforehand these are
largest, more important
at the top in terms of revenue.
There's actually
a function in GT
that's maybe less well known.
It's called row_group_order().
It's for changing the
order of these row groups.
And you just do that by a vector
of the names of the row groups.
And luckily, they have that.
It's basically just
countries_ considered.
Great, now if we run this, we
should get it in the order.
Yeah, exactly.
US, GB, DE.
Perfect, that's what we want.
It is important.
Sometimes you want exactly
the order you want,
and it's kind of frustrating
to put in that order.
There's other ways
to do it beforehand,
but this is a nice easy
way of doing it in GT.
Great, so we have
real good order.
Now we're going to do
a ton of stuff just
to make the table present well
and there's lots of things.
So one thing we might
do is format the numbers
so they're actually
in currencies.
Right now, this is
just USD amounts.
But they don't look like that.
So we'll use fmt_currency().
And the cool thing
about that is you
can just use columns
= everything.
And then all columns,
which are here in the body,
will be formatted as such.
And you do have this
currency argument
but it's already set
to USD, so we don't
have to do anything there.
One thing we might do
is, we don't really
need the pennies involved.
So we just might say
use_subunits = false.
Now let's see what
that looks like.
All right, not bad.
That's pretty good.
That's more what you want,
because these are big figures.
You don't really
care about the cents.
It's just rounded,
essentially, in this case.
Good, OK.
So now we have that
formatting in place.
If we scroll down, we see
we have some NA values.
So while we're doing
formatting, you
can actually use a formatter
or called format missing.
So it's fmt_missing().
And if you just use
that on everything--
So the first
argument is columns.
I just use that everywhere,
so I'll use everything().
And then what it'll do is
it'll go in and find every NA
and just use a default
replacement text.
You can set it, but the
default is this em dash
which is quite nice.
Again, you can set
it with any word.
You can use Markdown,
it's totally up to you.
But the default is pretty good.
OK, so that's fmt_missing().
Another new feature in GT,
which is kind of cool--
It's basically in the
last release of GT,
--is, you can take these row
groups and make them columns.
So it's a little
hard to access that.
It's actually in tab_options().
But I'm going to show
you how to do that.
So it's actually tab_options(),
and tab_options() has just got
so many different options that
you probably want to tab to see
what they are.
You can actually do a
fuzzy search in here.
The option that we
need is row_group.
There it is-- as_column.
And then you just use a TRUE.
By default, it's false, but
we want true in this case.
OK, so now it looks like this.
So we have row groups, but
now they're to the side.
And it displays nicely,
because you just
have these bundles of
rows, which are nice.
Great, so now we have that.
I think what we got to do now
is take those numbers in the top
and make those month names.
And we have that,
which is great.
We have this month_names
list right here.
And what you can
do in cols_label(),
which is the thing you use
to relabel the column names,
is you can pass in a list.
So it's like this
.list argument.
So that list will be this right
here, this month_names list.
So if you just pass
that in, I believe
that's all you got to do.
Let's run this.
Yeah, now we get the months
as these short three letter
months, which is great.
Better than numbers, I'd say.
OK, so we have a table
that's looking like it's
developing pretty well.
One thing we could do, and
it's always fun to do that,
is add some context to
what these months are.
Or maybe there's special
things about these months.
So you can add spanners
above column names.
We do that with
tab_spanner right here.
And if you're using the
development version of GT,
we now have the ability
to have multiple spanners.
Previously, you could only
have one level spanners,
but if you're using the
development version,
I'd definitely encourage that.
You get multiple
spanners, which is great.
And I'll show you how to create
multiple spanners in a very
logical and easy to use way.
So tab_spanner(), the first
thing I want to do is, well,
say what year this is.
I know it's kind of
ridiculous, but we'll
say this is label = "2015."
And this is fake data.
I just gave the year
2015 on the line.
But that's what it is.
So then we'll use columns.
and we'll span this over every
column with everything(),
like that.
OK, 2015.
Great, OK.
And since this is fake data,
I could just make up stuff
everywhere.
We'll add some more spanners.
And we'll just say the
first three months,
there's a certain version of
this game out, version 1.0.
So we'll call this label
v0.1, and the columns will be
everything().
They will actually be c
and backtick 1, 2, and 3.
I'll show you two
styles of doing this,
but these are actually the
names of the columns themselves
in the original data.
So I'll give it
this, and we'll see
that this now appears
over those first three
columns, which is great.
So now we do the rest.
What version was the next one?
I think 1.2?
We'll skip 1.1.
We'll just put that, then.
OK, so 1.2, and we can access
columns in a different way.
We can just say 4:12,
but they can't be numbers
they have to be a character.
So we did this, right
here, as.character().
Great.
So, just so you know,
it gives you this.
So if you run the whole
thing, we now get this.
Great.
Now we have two
levels of spanners,
which is kind of cool.
It gives the extra context
about, this is 2015,
these are the months, and
this is some extra information
about what version of the game
was out during these months.
OK, great.
Now that we have that, we should
put a header in this table
so we can identify and give
it a nice title and subtitle.
So we do that with
tab_header, and there's
two things you put in here,
a title and a subtitle.
Subtitle is optional, but
it's always nice to have.
And we'll call this
"Revenue Amounts
by Country and IAP Types."
Let's do IAP Type.
Great.
Subtitle we can use Markdown.
So inside here, we can
have Markdown text,
and it'll be formatted as such.
So we'll say this.
"Considers--" and
this will be bold--
"Top Eight Countries
by Overall Revenue."
We have to close this off.
I'll put this down below,
for clarity, like so.
Let's run this.
And we'll see a title.
Looks good.
Markdown did carry
over, which is nice.
Sorry, I have an extra paren.
I'll get rid of that.
One thing we can do
is, if this is not
enough space between
the rest of the table,
because we're using Markdown, we
can throw in some line breaks.
So br, like so.
You have to put in
two to actually force
this amount of area.
So we'll see if this is good.
Some people may like this, have
a little bit of extra breathing
room before we actually
get to the table.
So that's a nice little
trick you can use.
Great, so now we
have the header.
We could do things like,
there's these opt functions,
like opt_align_table_header().
You may want to to the left,
so there's an option here
just to align it to the left.
I mean, it gives a nice look.
As long as we style everything
else to go with this,
it could be good.
OK, one thing we're missing
is this large gulf of space.
We don't have to create
there, but it's kind of
nice to put something there.
This is the stub, essentially.
So this is called the stub head.
We can actually just
put a label there.
And we also use Markdown, just
like we did before to do that.
So this is a tab_stubhead(),
and the only argument is label.
And we'll use
Markdown, and we'll
say "Region and IAP Type."
And again, if you want to force
a line break because we're
using Markdown, you can
do it right in the middle
here if you want.
If you just want to guarantee
that this breaks there.
So let's take a look here.
Great, excellent.
OK, so we got that now.
Now we can style this
thing quite a bit,
because right now it's
just a plain table.
I mean, it looks fine.
It has all the information
but it's not a whole heck
of a lot of style here.
So let's style a
little bit, first.
And then we'll get into
coloring the data as well,
because that's always
fun and good to do.
OK, so we use tab_style.
This is the thing
where you target
different areas of the
table, and you apply a style.
So in this case, I just
to make all the text
a little bit smaller in
the body of the table.
They're overwhelmingly large, so
I'm going to do that right now.
So I'm going to say it's
going to be style = cell_text,
and we'll say the size--
there's a bunch of arguments,
but size is one of them.
Here's the list of arguments.
And this is HTML thing,
like a CSS thing,
you just say "smaller," and
it'll just make it a bit
smaller than the default.
And with tab_style(),
you always have to
put in locations.
So in this case, I
will use cells_body.
If you're targeting all
the cells in the body,
you don't have to
put in the arguments.
It's already
targeting everything.
So let's run this, and
we'll see that this becomes
just a little bit smaller.
Yeah, and now actually
fits, width-wise, into--
Because, right now, we're
just sizing everything
by the size of the content.
But now making it smaller
makes it a little bit nicer.
These are a bit larger.
These are maybe less
important, especially as you
color the cells themselves.
They become a little
bit less important.
OK, now we have tab_style.
We did that.
The next thing we're going
to do is, like I said,
we're going to
color all the cells.
So we can use the like the
function called data_color.
Really kind of tough to use.
I always recommend going to
the help, data_color, like so.
I could barely
remember how to use it,
because it involves using
scales functions inside of it
for the colors argument.
Luckily, there's
examples in here,
and they show how they work.
But it's always a bit of
a challenge, even for me.
But for this, we know we need a
few arguments that we see here.
So we're going to
use columns first.
We're going to use
we're going to consider
all the columns, all the
body columns in the table,
which is great.
And they're going to use
scales::col_numeric()
as a function of the scales.
Palette, this is going
to be a little strange,
but I'm using two greens.
And the first green I'm
going to use is "#66FF--"
I'll make that capital FF--
"00."
And this is a
little bit strange.
I'm going to use the same
color like the high amount,
except I'm going to use alpha.
The strange thing about alpha
in scales::col_numeric() is you
don't provide alpha value,
you provide true or false.
And where you provide
the alpha thing
is right here in
the color itself.
So you can make color
names have an alpha part.
So zero alpha is there.
So this is the low value and the
complete opaque one is FF, OK?
Very strange, the way you do it.
But it makes sense.
It just says
whether you consider
the alpha part of the color.
OK, great.
So also, we're going to
choose the na.color, just
a random color.
Let's see OK, maybe
one more F and 66.
Is that right?
12345678.
OK, good.
And what else?
Oh yeah, the most
important one is domain.
And this is where we can choose
the limits, like the range
of where the colors go.
If you just want it to be the
data itself, you just use null.
OK, that simplifies
things a bit.
OK is that it?
Hope that's it.
Yeah, it seems like that's it.
So you did provide columns.
You did provide a function here.
This argument is called
colors, unfortunately.
But if you have that,
then you're good to go.
So I'm going to run this
and hope that it just works
OK it does, which is great.
So we can see here that the
values here are colored.
Dark greens are
high values these
are low, almost transparent
greens are less values.
So just the way
to map around, see
if revenue has grown during
months that we've had the game,
and in which regions the
revenue is not so great,
you can see here.
And the na.color is right here.
So basically, any NA
values are in this color.
So that's good.
Otherwise I think
would be a dark gray,
and maybe that's just not jiving
with the color scheme here.
OK, so that's the color.
Great.
So now we're going to
do things like fill out
the table a bit more.
So we're going to
add source notes.
So to do that,
we're going to add--
let's start with
tab_source_note.
And for each source
note you add,
you basically make a new
call of tab_source_note.
And the argument
here is source note.
And, again, you can
use Markdown for this.
And we can just say,
the source of the data
we just got, this
is all pretend.
We'll just say, "All
revenue figures obtained
from daily retrievals from
the--" again, we have Markdown,
so let's just say
"App Annie API."
There's a period.
I believe that closes it off.
Let's run this.
OK then we have to go right
to the bottom to see it.
There it, which is great.
And this is italicized,
which is fantastic.
OK, so we're going to
keep going with this.
We'll add another
source_note just
to show you that you
have a whole bunch
and be in that order that
you specified them in.
And this one, we'll say the
idea is to start with all.
Get rid of this.
"All reporting shown here
was created by the--"
And again, you can use
crazy Markdown, like this,
italics and bold.
We'll say central
data science team.
So let's run this.
And again, we'll
scroll to the bottom
and see that it
was added, and it's
in the same order,
which is wonderful.
And we're going to add
some footnotes now.
We're just going to
fill out this footer
and then we can sort of see that
like interesting things could
be shown there, and you can
have footnote references
in the table.
And adds a bit more context
where you might need it.
So just tab_footnote.
In this case, you'd
need an argument, which
is footnote and locations.
So it's kind of
like to tab_style,
where you need the locations.
So I'm just going to
put that in for now.
But the footnote here might be--
well, let's maybe put footnotes
on where there's like missing
data, and we'll explain it.
I think that's
not a bad idea OK,
we'll say that "These figures
are $0 or less," we can say,
"Due to refunds," which
is totally a possibility.
And locations.
So if you have
multiple locations,
like we have two
different columns,
we can make a list of
locations, like so.
And we just separate each of
the cells' calls with a comma.
OK, so cells_body, and we'll say
first one is in columns = '1.'
That's our original
column name, and we have
to say which rows they are.
In this case will say rows
= is.na('1'), like so.
Unfortunately, we
have to do it twice
because we have two
different columns
and we can't just refer to
the column like in this rows
expression.
But it's not too bad.
That may change later on.
So in this case, we know
there's one in month three,
so we have to do this.
Great, and hopefully this works.
I can run it to see if it does.
OK, it didn't complain, and we
do see a footnote right there.
Great.
And we do see it in
the right places.
It's not anywhere else besides
the NAs, which is great.
I love that.
OK, more footnotes?
Yeah, I mean just having
one footnote is not great.
So we're going to
add a few more.
I know a little bit
tedious but, you're
going to love all the
footnotes, I swear to you.
OK, tab_footnote.
Great, OK.
In this case, let's
see, what's a good one?
Something notable.
OK, right here, Norway.
There's a huge jump
in the revenue.
I mean we should explain this.
OK, so let's do that.
Let's target this cell with a
footnote and some explanation.
So a footnote,
it's going to be--
we'll make this Markdown,
down just for fun.
"A surprising jump in
**gems**," in bold.
"Revenue from the previous
month. " OK, period,
and we'll put a
comma on the outside.
Is that right?
Yes.
And now we need a
location, so we'll
say locations is going
to be cells_body.
Columns will be the 12th month.
OK, this one's a bit
tricky, because usually you
can specify by the label here.
But they're all the same,
which makes it impossible.
It's just gems, gold, offer.
Gems, gold, offer.
So we can't do that.
So we have to actually
use an expression,
and we have to make sure it is
just for this cell, which is
not great, but we will do it.
So we'll say rows
is going to equal--
because it's on that column.
Basically just how
we got the value.
We'll just put the value in.
Round('12') == 6278.
OK, that means I can't think
of another way to do it.
So this is not bad.
OK so hopefully--
yeah, I see it.
It's right there and
it's nowhere else
because no other
value is that value.
Great, good. so now
we have two footnotes,
I specified in the
order I wanted,
it and it just appeared in the
right order, which is awesome.
Got to have it.
OK, now we're going to add
even more footnotes on top.
But we can explain what
these version numbers are,
and where we're going to finish
the footnotes after that.
Because I like to have
a bunch of footnotes
because more numbers.
And we could do more stuff
in there, like I said before.
So tab_footnote.
Footnote is going
to equal, we'll
say, put this in backticks.
That will make it a
code font, like so.
We'll say, "The v1.0 build used
the first version of the offer
agent SDK," because we're going
to explain that the offers were
pretty bad up until the
second version came out.
Just coincidentally,
it picked up.
So we'll say the offer
system was broke initially.
So we got that.
Put a comma on the
outside, because this
is the Markdown part.
Locations, and this will
be cells_column_spanners(),
and this is going to be spanners
equal to exactly the label,
"v1.0."
This is actually the ID, but
the label becomes the ID.
And you can specify
an ID if you want,
but usually you just
want the label to be
the ID for easiness's sake.
OK, we're going to do
the exact same thing,
I'm just to copy this
to explain the 1.2 part.
And it's really
just changing this.
We'll say, "The 1.2
build," What did it do?
It added more.
Well, it got better.
Let's see, "Added
more missions,"
basically get free DLC.
"More missions and had an
updated offer agent SDK."
Great, that's closed off, and
we'll say spanners = "v1.2."
That's what it's called.
OK, so I'm going
to run this, and we
should get way more footnotes
than we've have ever seen.
More footnotes, great.
I see them here.
One, two, and then there
should be a third here.
Great.
And then repeating fours.
And there they all are.
Great, this is so good.
I'm loving this table so far.
I mean it looks so great.
This is fake data.
I wish it was real data, because
this is too good to be fake.
OK, anyways, so
let's keep going.
One thing I like to do is change
the widths of all the columns
right away.
I don't want it to
be left up to chance.
So I'll just say everything
is going to be 75 pixels wide.
And let's take a look at that.
This is something you do and
you just adjust it all the time.
Oh no, it does not work
So you've got to be careful here
not to use just everything().
It's not a column name.
Great, thank you.
Now we should see--
Yes, this looks great.
Now everything is that
width, which is perfect.
Here's a crazy trick.
It's a trick where you
want to specify the column
widths of these, but they don't
come with column names, really.
You can just use
a number, like 1.
And now, actually,
refer to this, not this.
It's a little bit strange,
but with column widths,
it assumes everything
is a column now,
and we're just going
to change everything.
So you do 1, and make this
a bit smaller so px(50), OK.
So now that first one
should be narrowed down.
As we see, it's shrunk down
a little bit, which is good.
A recent version
of GT add a bunch
of new functions for padding.
They're all in the opt
series of functions.
Once called
opt_horizontal_padding.
And we're going to
do a thing where
we scale it to be more padding.
And I'll show where
I'm going with this.
Because we have all the
values like butting up
against the edge, a
little bit of space,
but we want to maybe
center it a bit.
I think it might look nice.
So let's try it.
So this will take all the
data in here, basically
all the cells, it will
just bring stuff in.
See, now it's more toward
the center, but still right
aligned.
It's kind of nice.
And this is actually
brought in as well, so
everything lines up.
It's really nice.
One function, it just
scales of having.
And this can be between
0 and 1 as well,
if you wanted to
be less padding.
So that's how that works.
While we're on the
padding tip, we just
use opt_vertical_padding
as well, because why not?
And we'll try to get
this a little more dense.
So we'll say the scale,
in this case, is smaller.
We want less padding in
the vertical direction.
So we should see a bit of a
tightening, which is great.
And I'm going to make
this this a bit bigger,
so you can see more of this.
Good, this is really shaping up.
OK, so we did the
padding thing, and now we
want to do even
more style stuff.
I guess we'll do
some more tab_style.
Because I think what
you want to change now
is the row groups themselves.
Yeah, we want to differentiate
these categories.
So let's do that right now.
So we'll say
tab_style, and we'll
make it on the locations, which
equals to cells_row_groups.
And it just needs all of them.
And the first argument is
actually the style itself.
We want to change the
text and the background,
so we'll put it in a list,
and make sure there's a comma.
Cell_text, we'll say
the color of the text
is going to be a CSS
color called snow.
The weight, we'll make it bold.
And we'll align it to the right.
It may not make much of a
difference, but let's try it.
OK, so we have that.
Now we'll do cell_fill.
And now we want the
color to be slate gray.
I do it in caps because
that's how it is in CSS,
but you can do it
in all lowercase.
It's the same thing.
And we'll add an
alpha that's actually
an argument here of 0.5.
So blends a bit nicely
with the background
we may add in the future.
OK, so let's add this.
It takes a little while,
but it's worth it.
So now we have this.
Great, good stuff.
Now we'll do another thing.
There's this other opt
function called opt_all_caps.
It just adds a bit more style.
It makes the surrounding
chrome in this caps type
of style, a small caps.
It's not too bad.
I sometimes add that,
because it's kind of nice.
And now we can change the
font with opt_table_font.
And we can use the font,
which is a Google font.
And we can just choose a name.
And I know there's a bunch.
There's a few of them.
One, I like, is Karla.
We'll add that in.
We'll see an immediate
change in the table.
It looks really good.
I like this.
And now to finish
it off, we'll just
add a ton of different
options in the table,
because there's so
many things you can do.
I might go very
quickly through this.
But options, I
recommend getting tab.
You can search through.
There's little
descriptions here.
But we'll just change things to
make things a little bit nicer
in the table.
So we'll do the
table.background.color there.
And we'll choose "LemonChiffon."
Great.
That's maybe a bit too bright.
One thing we can do,
we have this function
in GT called adjust_luminence.
We can wrap the color in it, and
there's an argument there which
I believe is called steps.
And we can make that 2.
And this could be
totally adjusted to suit
what you think is good.
OK, great.
I'm going to make this
so you can see the rest.
OK, great.
So that's that.
And I'm going to make
even more options here.
So heading.background.color
I'm going
to do the same sort of
thing, except I'll just
keep "LemonChiffon"
without the change.
The other thing I'll try is
footnoes.background.color.
So I'm just changing a bunch
of background colors here.
I'm just going to
put them in here,
and then change
them all at once.
Footnotes, and then I want
source_notes_background_color.
Great.
Just prepping it up.
What else could we do?
We can just copy this
here and just change
the amount of steps.
It's not a bad thing that we
have a variation on one color.
So in this case, I think I might
bring it back -0.5, and maybe
the same thing here,
because they're actually
separate locations.
I'm going to run this
so you can actually
see what's going on there.
And we'll zoom to the
bottom so you can see
what colors have been changed.
So right here,
it's a bit darker.
It's almost similar to this.
Great, OK.
A few more things, and then
I swear this will do it.
So you might want
to do a thing where
you cap the table on
the top and bottom.
You can change the table border,
the very top and bottom border.
So I think it's
table.border.top.width.
And we can use the function
px() to find pixels.
Just put it in there.
And we could do
the same thing with
the table.border.bottom.width.
Sorry.
here we go.
Great, so now we have those.
OK, another thing we
need to do is footnotes.
There's this multi-line
option now in GT.
Right now, there are
multiple lines by default.
We can just say
false and they'll all
appear as one paragraph,
which is kind of cool.
Another cool thing we can do
is table.body.hlines.style.
We can change the style
of the lines themselves,
because there's
quite a few lines.
We'll just make it dotted.
You can also do dashed,
and solid is the default.
What else?
We can change the
heading.title.font.size, just
make it pretty big, px(30).
And we do the same thing with
the heading.subtitle.font.size,
make that a bit smaller.
this just bumps up in size.
OK, after all this, let's
take a look at our table.
This may be the final table.
I mean, I did a lot to this.
So let's make this
a little wide.
We sort of see what we've done.
This is now huge, but
it's nice, because it's
a bit bigger than the rest,
makes it more title-like.
This looks pretty good.
See the dots?
There's different sizes of dots.
A little hard to see
because the contrast,
but it's lightens things a bit.
And again, we have
the footnotes.
They're all one paragraph.
Just for the footnotes
part, the source notes,
you can change the
way that is laid out.
But in this case,
we did not do that.
We just have them
as separate lines,
because muti_line = TRUE.
But we can set that to false
if you want a paragraph.
Yeah, and this is our table.
Not too bad.
If you have real data,
it's even better,
but fake data is always
great to have because--
What are you going to do?
You don't have data.
You need to get some.
OK, so that's my that's
my GT demo for today.
Hope you enjoyed it.